( intro music )
Caleb Harper:
My talk is about how to solve
the global food crisis
Technology and seed
is for an adverse world.
What if you had perfect world?
Researching this for me
took me to a place of learning
about Mir Space Station.
You know, the most space
constrained environment
the least amount of resources.
You know it costs
them a lot of money
to ship water into space.
So, they created something
on Mir called Aeroponics.
That was inspirational to me
where they create
a fog in a box.
And that fog is between five
and fifty microns dense
and all of those microns
of water contain also
all the nutrients and the
oxygen the plants need.
The thing that inspired
me is they reported
that they use 98
percent less water.
And that they grew anywhere like
a theoretical possibility of
twenty times faster
plant production.
So, one square foot of soil
three heads of
broccoli in a year.
That's if you have the water,
if you don't have pests
if you have the fertilizer
if you... if, right?
The farmer "if".
Whereas in Aeroponics
we're producing 18.
What if,
I just took one square foot of
the tallest
building in Boston
just one on the whole facade
I get between three
in the ground
or 3,000 in that facade.
So, we started by
hacking things from
Home Depot, Bed Bath and Beyond
you know, atomizers, nebulizers
learning about the
technology of creating mist
making plants dance
killing a lot of
plants, unfortunately.
You know, we were technologists,
a group of technologists
falling backwards into
a very old world.
So, then we went to the
first 60 square feet.
Inside of this
60 square feet
we're experimenting with
all kinds of things
But I think most importantly
we fed about 300 people in
the Media Lab, once a month
and we made a lot of
local food donations.
But even better than that
the bright green colors
the bright white roots,
the crispness
the quality of all of this food.
You know, is this a new
grocery store of the future?
Is this is a new restaurant?
Is this just a pick your own
lettuce patch for dorks?
( audience laughter )
This was the first time that
many people in the Media Lab
had ever ripped the
roots off of anything.
You know,
it's just a reality.
We get our salad in
bags, and that's
there's nothing wrong with
that, we live in the city but
you know, this created a spark
of inspiration that said
"Well, maybe, you know, maybe
image based processing
and machine learning
has something to do with food."
You can log into this farm.
So, you log in, you
monitor the system.
You get a history.
That history becomes
a digital recipe.
These are all the broccolis
in my lab by IP address.
Right. We have IP
addressable broccolis.
We create all this cool stuff,
now we got to email it.
Why are we shipping things?
Why are we shipping with planes,
trains and automobiles?
Why can't we email food
like we email information?
So, Willy Wonka style why
can't we particalize it
and then send it over
to the other side
to be reconstituted
somewhere else?
If this seems crazy,
we're already doing it.
These are labs that I am
sending all over the world
in different places.
So, this really becomes
just a platform.
So, here's the tools.
First personal computer for food
we call it GRO-bot.
GRO-bot is a hacker platform
for kids.
we're trying to get
this done super-cheap
and send it all over the world
This is what I am doing.
I am connecting school
children that experiment
and want to know why
does a plant grow tall
why is it short,
why does it taste funny.
Why does algae
grow in the water?
But then we are recording that.
And they can email that
to their friend
but even more importantly, say
they express a novel protein
and that novel protein is
incredibly important to humanity
we never knew it existed
because those climates that
the kids created playing,
don't exist on Earth.
So, if you can distribute all
of this across the world
you can make breakthroughs
so much faster.